you probably deal with it more
emotionally yourself because it's a
vicious circle you want more so you
happy
Universal CityWalk so it's not close and
$25 to park let's do this man really yep
sometimes you procrastinate before you
start a podcast we just been sitting
here eat food Oh doughnuts Qin bought us
twelve left two minutes car overnight
that's all right it's in the old they
lost all their moisture so what I'll
tell you they're all stuck together
they're all stuck together all night the
icing is delicious my pancreas is
shooting out a lot of insulin right shin
how was your how was your voodoo
doughnut experience where'd you go
Studio City it's in Universal CityWalk
if you go to Universal Studios you know
side thing over and next to it yeah the
city wok area so that's our way it was
Abby's to get know the only thing is the
parking cost $25 there's just no way
around it unless you're sneaky and you
gotta have my dog how many donuts 12
what it cost you totaled up so I got you
guys I got my roommates and then the
parking was about a hard under 700 total
but the donuts should have cost around
14 15 bucks for the Dozen no more and
more no three bucks each no no no I was
just there they're a dollar something is
that true yeah you know what it came out
to like $45 45 bucks and then 25 for the
parking so maybe you're inflating a
little bit 70 bucks math find a magical
30 dollars in your pocket I was just it
just right so today was officially the
last day we film in this studio and it's
crazy just hit me as soon as I was about
to walk out so say goodbye to all this
stuff
amazing mural by visual Vega that took
basically two days non-stop and when I
saw him he looked like he was about to
pass out because he inhaled too much
paint and all this good stuff well we'll
bring
we'll bring that stuff but the wooden
wall behind it Brennan knew a guy that
builds movie sets and he did that for us
and then that's behind there is a I
won't talk about it and this is really
cool
it's a plaque that YouTube sent us
showing that T fat K surpassed a hundred
thousand subscribers
what's really really cool about this is
that the guys after they left Fox they
had to start from a clean slate on
YouTube and it built up to this many
subscribers like within less than a year
and now we're just a little over a year
in
and we're at around 180 something
thousand subscribers so enormous
shout-out to you guys thank you guys so
much really cool posters that a fan sent
which is awesome that MJ framed for us
we'll see you at the next one this sucks
balls
[Music]
and this is gonna be a nightmare
everything was pushed off of the wall
taken off of the wall so that the
painters could come in and paint this
place but of course the painters were
not able to make it in and now I have to
put all this stuff back up so we can
film today's episode look at what I
bought for the studio it's from a
company called the great small pretty
bad answer hopefully it doesn't fall and
there it is there we go
and we got this packaging it's the
golden zebra special delivery from big
g-shock adidas boost pretty dope I think
I don't know anything about sneakers so
but thanks Jay you look tired bright
brain O'Brien not tired I'm sorry no I
have a backpack of energy I have what's
called an extra backpack of stamina
brother and our force March throw your
[ __ ] y9 and this is me
oh my smart Mike Mike Mike I want you to
keep your eyes on my belt loop don't
take them off my belt loop I want you
smelling my [ __ ]
and then finally I take my belt and I
wrap it around your [ __ ] head I'm
dragging the only shoe I got it and the
other thing is because of your skin is
not built for the Sun no you're you're a
[ __ ] bright your tomato the model
you're conveying Amala your tomato I
can't protect you against sunstroke and
your lungs are gone out and your feet
and everything else just don't have the
stamina rap I want you smell my ass or
the whole way grab you by the ears look
you in the eye go that smell man oh boy
let's do this do the my chest
ok cool double dip double double dipping
dipping [ __ ] are you [ __ ] oh yeah
I don't have kids
ha ha
still too slow all right
what's too slow
I'm not matching up to my benchmarks I
know okay one more time boom so wrap it
follow this makeup on my face begins to
match it's time to go but I think this
second to last three okay there's two
out of the last thing that were really
good right okay I think there's like one
money faster so do you harmonize with
yourself yeah okay so I'll probably be
like there's something what do you think
Jen go with what you feel first okay
we'll start building on that Wow I feel
like some fun falsettos you know
something like there's something in
there yeah sure so this one's I was
sharp that's right okay so I got another
time to go got it I'll round that out
it's time to go below the belt below the
belt it was a different timing but I
gave you that option [ __ ] yeah that's
good that's good
one more one more alright Oh face begin
some air time to go dude one more
hey that's what I like to do this is one
chin and I just it's all gravy at this
point oh hey it's your 2018 fighter and
the kid guest of the year skylar astin
here get ready for the sabotage I just
recorded a nice little ditty for
Brendan's Showtime show you'll hear it
by next week
oh really Chris D'Elia you haven't given
me one of these but you've given one to
Brendan and Brian so here's what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna take your pin
I'm gonna take your little certificates
not gonna do anything bad to them
because I know you spent a lot of work
but I'm gonna keep them for myself
because I'm a true baby you understand
me I'm a true baby it's free conch drew
baby and this is the aftermath Gabe from
Showtime and Skyler was just here it is
exactly you see that 12 a.m. in the
morning literally no one - the automatic
lights went on but no one's here just
all right
and this is day 2 around 8:30 in the
morning we had like no joke about 60 70
or so different takes and then I added
another 20 20 or little bin 120 so takes
four just harmonies so we definitely had
a lot of stuff to work with now it's
going back this is day three and I'm
just about to pass out see what time it
is
149 and as you can see this is a
temporary setup I have my cheese here
seaside rugged mature English cheddar
from Whole Foods this is many people I
use this to play all the instruments
that I that's my monitor
it's temporary that's my anchor USB hub
that's my Kensington trackball mouse
which I need I programmed each button to
do what I needed to do four Pro Tools
that's my focus right for tape that I'm
gonna actually probably give away to
someone I figured out soon and this is
awesome but I've had it for so long and
yeah I feel like I should want to give
away it's been so good to me I want to
give to someone else and then other
something else
there's my electric guitar my beats
headphones and my brother gave me that I
off I wanted so badly and of course I
realize how bad they are but they're
actually good if you wanted to listen to
bass
if you won't listen to like fun pop
songs and rap songs they're great
they're just not good for actually
monitoring if you're into professional
audio
[Music]
[Applause]
so all this makeup on my face begins to
man
out what's up there he is
what's going on hey guys doing you guys
get you guys don't care about what's up
that's me too snacks this is for someone
else's okay dude these things are sweet
holy crap how much time you put in this
the fighter in the kid won this one
probably forty hours dear God yeah and
this is your passion passing a passion
yeah yeah side job
oh you're badass at it dude holy crap
that thing is enormous do daddies yeah
awesome man
yeah I'm going away right now dude
energy blown away
yeah hold on well it is heavy tonight
and it likes and there's lights yet with
the remote different colors dude oh yeah
okay
maybe go like right I'll show you this
I think the camera will catch it but I'm
sure we'll see that yeah ready quest
holy crap dude
aren't you freaked out you might get
like nudged by a car or something
they're all they're all strapped in yeah
took this 25 hours of driving you drove
in yeah holy Statham Portland and then a
few other places on the way if there's
like three two E's we did it
dear god that's freaking awesome that
stopped at the border where they try to
look for cocaine inside a door that is
so sick thanks so much right this thing
is enormous like so it's a power source
there
great work kid
[Music]
Oh instructions second drill in with my
just my hand but this is actually pretty
tough once this goes all the way through
it should be super strong and we won't
have to worry about this thing falling
on Brendon and Brian you see through
this thing
this is what I'm using see this so it
goes in all the way through the hole all
the way inside then it expands then you
push this part all the way back so it
grabs against the wall and then this
thing grabs against the wall this way
parallel that way and then it could hang
this is how we can hang this humongous
super-heavy mosaic that Ted made us push
this guy no snap this
[Music]
oh yes that's fine we'll just leave it a
little bit out and then I'll push it
what do you think of the car what color
is the skin as soon as you say that -
boom this is what I need for hiding the
wire in the wall the T flat case I and
wire fish tape
now for all you douche bags that kept
saying why'd you hide the wire no [ __ ]
[Music]
to be
[Music]
what's up man what's up the chimp can
yeah without the line uh Oh what do you
think
Kalin are you so excited about anything
[Music]
let's check back to city money - yeah
this is this is my dear friend Jack
this is my baby
again there is this a bother this about
the shop maybe shadowboxing can't make
it a meal of a wristband he's a man TV
man deal man bingo on you nobody gets
injured
[Music]
oh man
wait a minute tell me something Rosalie
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I got to go over how's that working out
I love it
how could we encourage me to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chin dude because super nice to meet you
man big fan of the podcast that's
awesome is your name Chris Chris yeah
Sumitra nice to meet you man it's a
great show tonight
he's a dude my first time seen a
stand-up really that like there's
there's like levels to this [ __ ]
yeah you know what I'm saying you see
the first two comics and then as soon as
Callen gets up he just dude [ __ ] you
smooth like I've seen it on on YouTube
and stuff like that but like it's such a
different monster when you see it live
man that's crazy
super proud man and an SEO I was telling
her to it's like put like oops I listen
in the podcast almost every single one
you know what I mean yeah and and so
like I always noticed you know Callen at
the end is always saying like there's
still tickets available
his jobs always just like I'm sold out
it's that simple they should both be
selling out do that okay once this thing
gets the prepares to be I just came out
of Brian stand up and oh my god
how good it was incredible
sure so man stop that steel fish tape oh
no if you can see it if it's focused in
or not steel fish tape and this thing is
made out of it as you can imagine steel
I have to drill a hole right where that
the lower part of the flag is something
really big so I can extract this guy put
it through the wall and it's nice and
firm because there's insulation in there
so it's nice and firm it'll go it'll
pass through that installation it'll
fight its way through and I have to
somehow find it in the very bottom which
is gonna be that's gonna be a [ __ ] all
right I got this thing a Dewalt I guess
it's a wall saw
[Music]
[Music]
that's how much [ __ ] you got to do and
then from that point I'm gonna take that
thing to go all the way up back to here
pull it out and this is how you do it
start pulling it up you see it start to
go away there just to go back up in
there start pulling it out and then
there you go here's the adapter all the
way through the wall to the top and
that's that's how long this adapter so I
have to figure out a way to make this
look even less conspicuous I think I'm
gonna stick that in there have the
extension cord go underneath this
molding behind the molding and then
patch up the molding again
[Music]
you gotta works
[Music]
my mom and dad are about to visit me
right now to bring by food Korean food
and just regular stuff like dishes cups
and stuff like that it makes them feel
better so that's why I let them do it
and I love my mom and dad so we're about
to see him in a second
No
okay I'll be downstairs this guy was
hitting the [ __ ] out of the phone huh
[Music]
it's the only thing that sucks about
downtown Los Angeles just craziness
before here be careful this crazy person
[Music]
my street becomes mainstream yes dad has
ticket just chibin Ariana to know
anything everything's done
you're smelling staircase still on
oh good
together okay
and that was it like there she's
visiting me for a second
because they just got a lot better when
they
when they give me stuff like soap
shampoo napkins all that stuff toilet
paper
it's a crane family for you the guided
by a bunch of men that was Benson he was
being threatened well I don't give a
[ __ ] I just stab get out from the
cheaters that's the scene by the way
you're gonna run over this dude was
trying to get above her dick suck and
you [ __ ] the game up that's dead
we got special guest in late night who's
there
it's that champ baby yeah what's up man
oh no I'm taking over it man I'm taking
over
you already did take over I'm here for
my title belt whose seed is this sobs
this Brian see boy yeah boy bust
that's my count impersonation man oh
yeah you know yeah so it's like I gotta
I gotta figure out like what do I need
to get this place souped up I'm feeling
fortunate to be here with you guys in
the new studio I just had chin came over
from the fighter in the kid you know I
don't know if you know chin he is a he's
an Asian country musician
[Music]
and he go by GART Brook is his country
name and he's an extremely talented man
and you know and one thing it's fun to
watch is if you have an Asian friend and
they're playing the guitar playing the
piano watching their hands move it's
like watching a very small octopus do
the hurdles if you ever watched like a
like an Asian guy play the piano their
fingers are so small they kind of yeah
they have to grown a little bit even
when they move their finger up on a cape
a piano key is very high for an Asian
finger doctors too so you say that means
three for me son that means three these
old doctors don't get it man right now
Brendan's on the phone with max Holloway
shake shack Los Angeles I got a lot of
stuff actually a hotdog that's covered
with cheese and fries and this is a
Shake Shack smoke shock I think it is I
forgot what it was but it looks good and
this is the original this original Shake
Shack burger so that's a shot burger and
these are so freakin good we had these
in London I think it was least or square
me Brendan and J and they were I
couldn't believe how good they were
there probably and I'm just saying that
one time we had it it was probably
better than in and out but different
better but it's still better I'm gonna
be honest with myself I think I
definitely have a problem now I mean
don't get me wrong I'm not eating this
all at the same time two different hot
dogs two different burgers and then
fries and extra cheese extra cheese
extra shakes or shack sauce regular
condiments I'm part of the save a burger
and a hotdog for later but then I'll eat
a burger and a hotdog right now or I
don't know we'll see what happens
it was so good